this episode is presented by pagoda egg
[Music]
rolls
after superman lives died batman v
superman asylum got locked away
and jj abram's superman flyby crashed
down to earth jj
script that was the bomb warner brothers
just kind of snapped and said
all right you know what it you want
to launch a universe how's this
superman doesn't want to save people
batman is a murderer wonder woman is an
incel
and harley quinn takes three movies to
break up with joker who looks like my
co-dealer you all happy now you might
you're all fired i hate my job i'm gonna
go make spongebob spencer paramount plus
the dc extended universe
welcome to the dceu continuity that
compared to marvel's boring but reliable
b
student is a chaotic goth nerd who never
lived up to his potential
cause warner's does crap like change the
title after a movie comes out cancel
films they've already announced
publicly fight their own stars swap
directors mid-production
and release oopsies cuts of their films
to win back fans
in the sort of behind the scenes drama
you get when the closest thing you have
to a foggy
is donald trump's treasury secretary
sheesh no wonder these guys hated cyborg
meet your typical dceu protagonist
either a naive fish out of water
an angstfield warrior made of sadness or
a quippy jokes are stuck with joss
whedon's bee material
my special skills include uh viola a web
design
fluent in sign language they're way too
powerful to worry about
it kind of tickles but when they're
somehow threatened by an irritating
little wimp
ooh i love it
pokemon an army of faceless goons
or an angry lump of cgi
they'll harness the power of creatine to
squeeze into a series of costumes so
fetishized they should have their
own only fans silica based quartz sand
fabric
abrasion resistant heat resistant my
brother
i applaud your choices today it
shouldn't work but
hot damn it does make it through that
part of the movie where they lose their
powers
i got the wind knocked out of me need a
few seconds that's all
murder someone you can't leave him like
that
[Music]
and he's some kind of sequel character
or spin-off that will never get followed
up on
shouldn't we have a league of our own oh
snap
do you know who that is that's that's
the next director's problem
in a world dominated by disney's mickey
mouse club watch dc's effort to set
themselves apart
where marvel wanders what if the gods
were just like us dc answers
they're real and they want nothing to do
with you i used to want to save the
world
i don't want to be king yeah here's the
thing i can't be here
superman was never real the world
instead of adapting the best storylines
of their best comics
they'll let the guys behind blake
trinity and rise of skywalker take their
best shot
and instead of quipping all the time
that is america's ass
everyone talks like a 14 year old trying
to sound badass while they skim a wiki
page this is katana
she's got my back she can cut all you in
half with one sword stroke just like moe
on the lawn
i would advise not getting killed by her
her sword traps the souls of its victims
you know if it's a choice between this
and the quips then i choose the airbud
franchise
[Music]
experience a universe that rests on one
amateur bodybuilder's shoulders
zack snyder the inventor of the
feature-length movie trailer
because if trailers have all the coolest
shots then a four-hour long trailer
would be nothing but awesome i mean
right bro
watch as he reinvents dc's biggest icons
by taking all the color out
literally and metaphorically and whether
or not you're on board with this super
nihilism
cringe while the studio rips control of
his films away undermines the world he
created
and ensures that every fan he made will
reflexively hate anything they ever do
you know i'd expect better from the
people in charge of harry potter and
game of thrones
wait no i wouldn't of course they
screwed this up so before the flash
movie resets the timeline
or gets cancelled again or the star gets
canceled again
enjoy superhero movies for the
thoughtful and rage troll inside all of
us
where the only thing more dysfunctional
than what's happening behind the camera
is every dc hero's relationship with
their parents
i have to go back when i was a kid my
dad traded me for a six-pack of beer
didn't think you were ready for them to
see the monster you are not
a monster it's weird that you thought i
meant me
mom it's me
i had no father my mother sculpted me
from clay and i was brought to life by
zeus
well that's neat
story mcguffins the codex
is krypton's future the lost trident of
atlan
the god killer he's after the change
engine his mother box
we gotta cut her heart out a stone
started all this
the rock was lost it's a rock amazing
actors given nothing to do
do you really think that oh wow they
just
they really just vanish that's rude dumb
voice over
some days my childhood feels so very
far away and others i can almost see
it jules verne once wrote put two ships
in the open sea
without wind or tide it will come
together
there were perfect things diamond
absolutes
the truest darkness is not the absence
of light
it is the conviction that the light will
never return
bad wigs
[Music]
the one human being keeping these heroes
from becoming complete psychopaths
the director of wonder woman spewed with
warner brothers
the director of birds of prey spew with
the director of suicide squad spewed
with warner brothers
the director of aquaman he's pretty
chill with warner brothers actually
and the director of three dc eu
spewed with warner brothers hmm i'm
sensing a pattern here
you know they should let warner brothers
direct the movies that way everything
can be space jam too
crisis for infinite dorks
so many of these movies have a scene
where the hero is learning to fly but
can't quite get off the ground
what a perfect metaphor hey screen
junkies
in batman's one-man quest to fight crime
how many horrible crimes does he commit
himself
and does one of them violate the geneva
convention yes
in a new video we did the math on
batman's crimes harder than oracle on
tax day
click the thumbnail on the right to
watch it now
this episode is presented by pagoda but
the egg rolls in
what if i told you that you can like
both marvel and dc
it's not like my comment isn't clever
it's just that other comments are better
than mine
say something i'm giving up on udc